bear came along ripped up my saw house
again this sod house works out pretty
well for storing food most of the time
but I thought that for smaller amounts
of food if I just dug a hole straight
down in the ground a smaller hole it
might actually keep it even cooler than
this sod house does and also the Bears
might be less interested in digging into
it in the summer it can get up into the
80s here sometimes I've seen in 85
degrees cooler ground is gonna help me
to preserve food it's just like putting
it in a refrigerator the gravelly soil
is well drained I should be able to dig
down in here a few feet without getting
wet that feels nice and cool down here
got a nice sized hole on to the next
step so I'm looking for some spruce
trees in order to line my refrigerator
with them and a lot of the trees around
here just aren't suitable if I up use
trees that are too big it's gonna take
up a lot of space in that hole that I
dug it's they're too small think of how
many I'll need to build the height of
the wall so this is a happy medium one I
can reach around about that big that's a
good sized tree
I like variety I would not get into the
business of digging refrigerator holes
repetitively for a living but if I only
have to build one in my lifetime it's a
lot of fun
he's a little longer I can put five
gallon buckets and Eric probably fit
four of them in there
Barry's fish whatever I want to put down
in there meat it's gonna stay much
cooler on hot days and that's gonna help
me to keep food longer I think that's
gonna do it this started out as T
people's 14 years ago I cut them then I
shortened them to make a tent that I
could use in the winter now I'm gonna
cut them again I'm gonna use them as
part of my refrigerator lid
that'll be the lid right there I just
need to get some insulation
I got a nice thick piece of Moss to put
over the top of this I'll cut it right
here and I'll be able to just lift that
up it's not easy to find good moss
because there are a lot of roots and
trees in the ground I want a one
continuous piece for that door a nice
thick piece it's all attached at the
bottom by roots so I have to do
all I have to do is try it on for size
should fit right in there
got my refrigerate that should work
great